اي كلمات في محاوله بث الطمانينه لقلب هذه
الطفله المفزوعه ستظل طريقها على الاغلب
امام ذوي الانفجارات الشرسه في محيط
منزلها بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم حتى
حيل الجداد بامتصاص رعب احفادهن فشلت هذه
الجده على ما يبدو من تحقيقها
انه اليوم الرابع من ايام حرب كسر العظم
كما توصف بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع الحرب التي تزداد شراسه واتساعا مع
الايام قتلت منذ اندلاعها السبت الماضي
اكثر من 180 مدنيا واوقات نحو 1800 جريح
وفق الامم المتحده حتى اعداد هذا التقرير
وتخلف قصصا من الالم لدى نازحين بحثا عن
النجاه يتشاركون خلال رحله الاجبار هذه
مشقه اللجوء فبعضهم يفورو سيرا على
الاقدام وربما كان من سعداء الحرب من يجد
وسيله اخرى وحتى اللحظه تعجزوا على ما
يبدو تقارير محليه او دوليه عن تقدير
اعداد النازحين ورغم صعاب النزوح تبقى
خيارات من فارقوا ديارهم محدوده اذ تعم
رائحه البارود غالبيه المناطق في السودان
ثالث اكبر بلد افريقي مساحه واحد اكثر
البلدان فقرا في العالم
وربما تحيي موافقه الطرفين المتحاربين على
هدنه لمده 24 ساعه تنتهي مساء الغد تحيي
املها هؤلاء بهدوء يسمح لهم بعوده امنه
الى منازلهم حنان المصري العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات